does drew brees's
legacy is it different because of what
he means to the city of new orleans the
katrina thing
the one super bowl to a franchise that
was completely downtrodden i was
thinking about this while listening to
this interview right
most quarterbacks in drew brees position
where he was one of the best
quarterbacks that played the game in his
era
one super bowl you'd say man he left
some on the table
but there's something about what drew
brees means to new orleans the
post-hurricane katrina situation and
winning that one super bowl for a
downtrodden organization i don't know if
that feeling is there i don't know if it
feels the same as uh if peyton hadn't
won a second one or uh you know any of
these other name a list of guys like if
aaron rodgers doesn't win a second super
bowl people will look at it and say i
cannot believe that aaron rodgers didn't
win a second super bowl if drew brees
doesn't win a second super bowl i think
he'll be beloved no matter what
and it's an interesting dynamic i don't
know what it is exactly it might be the
new orleans thing it might be just that
everyone likes drew brees but don't you
think there's something there
i absolutely think there's something
there and what you're saying reinforces
my point he's a top five quarterback all
time i mean he's he's going to have
every record except most interceptions
brett favre is never going to give that
one up even though i'm sure he'd love to
and and we just take the guy for granted
right he's never in the mvp conversation
it's always offensive player of the year
not that anybody understands the
difference between the two and and this
guy has been consistent he's had some
incredible seasons he is a passing
yardage machine he's got more 5 000 yard
seasons i think than the rest of the nfl
combined although there that he may be
he may be a little bit behind that now
because there were one or two of them
last year roethlisberger and and uh and
patrick mahomes but but this guy has
been one of the best passers in the
history of the league and that story is
so unique you're right aaron rodgers won
a super bowl well the packers already
had three peyton manning won a super
bowl in in indianapolis well the colts
already had one the the he won one in
denver well the broncos already had two
i mean this is
a very very rare set of circumstances
the way everything went down the rebirth
of the city the the birth of a franchise
that had been downtrodden for most of
its history before drew brees arrived in
2006 i think that that that great story
added with his statistical achievement i
don't think it should be a debate that
he's one of the top five quarterbacks of
all time but i know guys like sims want
to fight me on that but it's more than
that mike it's more that you don't
really hear people saying well drew
brees never won another super bowl he
never won another super bowl you know
we don't even hear people saying well
drew brees never went back to another
super bowl that conversation doesn't
even happen so i just think it's very
interesting because the media
uh the entire like country of football
fans treats drew brees a little bit
differently than other uh
you know unbelievable quarterbacks and i
think it might be the new orleans thing
but i can't fully put my finger on it
because most guys in drew brees
situation they win one super bowl then
they're good
really good for another decade and
they're clamoring you see it right now
with aaron rodgers people are going to
say aaron rodgers only won one super
bowl brett favre same way he only won
one super bowl where was that second
super bowl where is that super bowl that
takes him kind of over the top and puts
him in that real conversation of
all-time great drew brees is there and
he only has one super bowl
yeah but far was there and he only has
one super bowl i mean but you know maybe
it's maybe it's going back to the super
bowl maybe going to another super bowl
is what what also counts because yeah
you know favre went to another super
bowl and
breeze having to get back to another
super bowl will mean a lot more
i i think that that the saints uh and
i'd love to se obviously it's impossible
to answer this question but if that
bounty gate baloney that the nfl trotted
out in 2012 at a time when plenty of
teams were doing the same thing but they
decided that they were going to change
the culture of the nfl as it relates to
bounties by finding one team that they
were going to hammer instead of putting
everyone on notice that hey you end the
bounties or we're going to hammer you
they found the saints they nailed the
saints they gutted the team from a
coaching standpoint a defense standpoint
in 2012 and it took them years to decor
to recover on the defensive side of the
ball meanwhile they're still hovering
around seven and nine eight and eight
every year
with abysmally bad defenses
and and and i i just i'd love to know
how competitive the saints would have
continued to be if they didn't have to
deal with that lost season of 2012
because 2011 remember that epic playoff
game against the 49ers i mean they were
still a team that was hanging around at
the top of the nfl and i think they
would have been more competitive they
would have more playoff appearances if
they didn't have to deal with 2012 in
the aftermath of it and i think bree's
presence and his skills kept that team
from spiraling out of control
yeah it's a good point it's a big time
what if that we will always get to play
and uh i i think if drew brees goes to
the super bowl he'll get that victory
lap that we're kind of talking about
where the media comes out and says you
know this guy's legacy it felt like it
was going to happen last year when you
had a little bit of mvp conversation
then he fell off towards the end of the
year the rams obviously come into the
superdome and win fair and square
and uh that that kind of changes the
narrative of the drew brees season this
is his last hurrah so to speak
yeah fair and square victory by the rams
that had no ramifications whatsoever on
the rest of the nfl and doesn't threaten
to undermine the nfl's 100 season by the
overreaction that the nfl engaged in
that i had nothing to do with let's just
make nothing
on there all right let's take a break
when we return antonio brown back at
practice in a different helmet while he
still fights for the right to wear the
helmet model that he wants to wear at
least for one more year we'll give you
the a b update when pfc live continues
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports